okay so first of all welcome to Comic
Con thank you have you gotten to go down
to the street see the costumes get the
crazy no sadly I haven't I've been a
hotel you know had to get hair makeup go
to the event last night and I'm here now
so listen I'm here for you okay I'll
have to experience them at a time
have you seen anything weird like
yesterday even in the hotel and stuff I
was in CVS and I saw like a poor from
Star Wars like a full dress like trying
to buy powder and I was like wow I'm at
comic-con nothing in the hotel yeah no I
haven't been sheltered in my room you're
so shelter sorry okay there are so many
stars that come to comic-con Chris Pratt
Nicole Kidman is there anyone you get
starstruck over whoo I mean I used to
have the biggest crush on Chris Pratt
like Andy Dwyer Chris Pratt right so if
I saw him you know I might I might give
a little peek but now he's like movie
star Chris Pratt yes I'm here yeah but
lean oh listen I I saw so much affection
for Andy Dwyer so that's who I see and I
know your sister's coming to for
Godzilla and is there any like sister
bonding time do you have any there's no
there's no overlap she I I I'm done
today she comes in a couple days so you
know maybe you know in the sky I'll just
wave to her and what do you like how do
you guys keep your relationship going
like you're both in this business it's
crazy for both of you like you go to
each other for advice or do you just are
she the only person that treats you
normal now that you know you mean no
geez I mean listen we're we're sisters
so that comes first before before
anything yeah I definitely think that
you know the fact they were both in this
industry and both actors that has
brought us closer because we we can
relate like I and she she can now
complain to someone who understands what
she's like as a rough day on set 19-hour
day you know so I think it's good for
her and good for me to be able to you
know have someone who fully understands
exactly what it what it entails
you're jumping into the the horror genre
I'm taking that crown sure when you were
growing up did you see any of her movies
like is this why you wanted to do horror
or you like odd were you allowed to see
them well I didn't really I didn't go I
didn't grow up watching horror films and
veera I mean I think most recently you
know she you know
she's done Bates Motel and the conjuring
and stuff but I mean that's a pity
yeah but it's been it's been more it's
been more recent so I you know growing
up watching her films it wasn't as scary
yeah I wasn't it wasn't a scary films
okay what scares you the most
God everything oh yeah I am the jumpiest
person anything anything demonic I don't
like opening myself up to that you know
I don't I don't know what I believe
about supernatural and ghosts but on a
kind of person that's like why open the
doors why I let it in because then I'll
get an answer and I don't want a
definite answer
well I heard a rumor that ghosts can
only travel in a straight line you feel
like a ghost is coming to like steps
your side or like to okay some advice
all right well keep it in my back thank
you
obviously fans of American Horror Story
very excited for this crossover season
and I know you appeared him of them says
there any chance that we could see you
pop up oh man um honestly I I don't know
you know the decision is not up to me
but I'm I'm happy to to go if they want
me okay if there was any if there was a
season I feel like this would be it but
it's gonna be in your scrubs I think
right do you have you heard anything
from those cast mates about how it's
gonna work and what the story like that
or maybe every place everybody is so
tight-lipped because I think you know
Ryan's got a good hold on them as like
no we got to keep it separate so people
are special I'm saying anything they
don't talk I swear to you I'm being
sincere they don't talk that Ryan I'm
sorry Helen oh and sometimes me but I'm
like trying to get secrets out too and
he's like no thanks my dad met with that
you know that little glint in his eye
but he doesn't he doesn't say um okay I
want to know for this how
you conjure up unintended the the fear
and the scared like are you just on or
do you actually have to think tell me
about that I know I mean listen the
thing yes it's a horror movie but you
know as an actress we're just
approaching it as real-life as a
character so for me it's not like okay
focusing I have to play the fear you're
focusing on oh no is someone around the
corner oh no what's that noise there's
someone behind me like so naturally your
body starts feeling that that anxiety or
that tension so the fear just comes
naturally but you already know what's
gonna happen cuz you've read the script
or do you know yes of course you read
the script but you know you have to let
it all go you forget about that you're
in your moment the whole thing is about
being present so okay you know you don't
think about the future
I'm not unless it's like a couple
seconds ahead okay I have to go through
that door it's dark okay so what I think
what I wanted to get from you now is
like a tutorial a little bit okay so
what I'll do is I'll just look at the
camera and you just tell me what to
think and I'll see like if I could
possibly movie star all right are you
ready okay mmm
I'm walking like I don't know all right
okay all right so you're walking down a
tunnel you turn left all this and the
lights seem to start dimming and you're
going down and as you go dark as you're
going as you look down the tunnel it's
just dark all of a sudden you hear this
little scratching noise okay okay listen
to me you hear the scratching noise it's
right behind you it's right on the walls
right in your ear okay all of a sudden
you feel this this little prick leanness
coming up your body it's the little
hairs on your body are sticking up
something's there something's there turn
around you see something nothing's there
turn around again there's nothing there
okay I'm not gonna take your job anytime
soon it's pretty good what do you think
I'd like to keep my job
listen you know I think there's always
room for improvement okay you know last
thing before I let you going to be here
to get Audi
you and beer I have done films together
last one was 2003 is the hunger alive
just you know I think I was mocking
talking 2013 is there any chance you
guys ever talk about working together
again um yeah I mean it hasn't been like
a serious conversation but honestly I
admire so much as an actress I would
jump at the chance and I think I think
she likes me I think she'd do it again
with me is there any possibility would
write something or like director oh I
you know I think the next thing I would
love is I would love to work with her
again as a director I think she's a
phenomenal director one thing I really
love is actors who turned into directors
because they really really know how to
how to communicate and get across what
they need emotionally for the actor yeah
so I would love to have her be my
director again